[Music]
so I was raised in the city basically my
whole life and I've never been camping
before never spent the night in the
woods never built a tent
never slept in a tent never pissed
outside so this is gonna be it's gonna
be something else you pulled up to the
campsite we came out all disoriented get
some gravel to sleep on to little fire
things right there there's a bunch of
cabins right there but we're not allowed
to sleep in the cabins because that's
not that's not true camping so what's
the first thing you do when you get to
that campsite you gotta find some
shelter so we take out this tent that
Jayde brought this tent is massive it's
got like 10 rooms in it it's a freaking
I don't know what you how fast is this
supposed to be assembled anyway I say
like give us 20 minutes took us about
like three hours to build this tent this
is the point of the video when we have
the motivational music Hughes and then
it's like a cool montage montage I'm
sorry I know how our format usually is
like oh my god people are put in an
uncomfortable situation and then oh my
god they succeed this video we don't
succeed
we have no transformation where's the
stake set a date hey baby
a dig is the stakes
all right I'm just gonna look sexy
looking lovely we're gonna have some
shelter tonight maybe how'd you get this
whole thing in a bag here's how it's
done
[Music]
it's good enough finally things are
starting to come into shape the tennis
darn it to look like actual ten welcome
to my crib where does the magic happy
guess what if you need a little more
magic you want three magics in one night
cold let's say someone is waiting for
you on the other side and you're like oh
like I don't want to see that person
that I just magic twit take the back
exit alright so everyone's stomach is
starting to growl and we need some food
so what are you gonna do you're gonna
try to start a fire no what
totally J tries to start this fire she's
like flicking some fireballs on some
cotton with some weird lip balm I don't
even know what's going on it's not
working so it didn't I decided to go on
an adventure as J just sits and chills
and tries to start a fire has anyone
even mentioned that we're in a place
called plate kill this place is called
plate kill all of a sudden it just gets
pitch-black like we were in full light
and all of a sudden we can't see
anything where are we going what is
happening today
there was no wood in sight we came all
the way back here and there's a fire at
the campsite they're just pouring
gasoline or whatever all over it you
know I'm actually impressed at anything
that we can actually make some more what
did you guys find when you're on your
walk by the way ourselves so I guess
cheers to the dream team the dream team
that should go camping don't change my
smell those guys
finally we all huddle up and we do what
you have to do whenever
in the woods we start telling scary
stories so we're a little nervous that
we might have oh my god just the one
thing that I did not want to happen why
are you in the car a day is a Scott like
two feet with nuts
so finally we like run out of the car we
get into the tent we lock everything off
somebody actually goes out to use the
bathroom and she tells us if something
happens to me save yourselves you don't
have to tell me twice
five minutes go by ten minutes go by so
we decided we should call her put this
camera on me because then it's gonna
happen to me
[Music]
[Music]
I love how we all just jumped as that
they even froze and then everyone
decided to go to bed after that terrible
experience no one could sleep all night
but nobody talked everyone just laid
there silently pretending like they were
sleeping while we had rocks jabbing into
our spines and that was not pleasant at
all I didn't sleep a wink but it was an
experience the only person who I did
good was Jade because she brought a
blow-up mattress okay I'm trying to
shower or something to look at
everything and pay more attention to
things
it's RV RV tent it's an RV site all
right we're packed up we are saying
goodbye to this campsite it was good
fresh air I feel like I had a chance to
breathe but I'm ready to take any smog
that the city offers yeah that's what
I'm using I'm ready for some smog it's
really creepy thanks for watching guys
tell us what to fail at next